who would win  scp-096 the shy guy or a nuclear bomb  nuclear bombs are some of the deadliest  weapons mankind has ever conceived from  their superheated blasts to their deadly  radioactive fallout while it's likely  the initial blast would sear off 096's  flesh with its extreme heat the shy  guy's true asset is its indestructible  skeleton if it survived the initial boom  its hyper regenerative ability would  mean that it's soon back on its feet the  jury is out on whether the radiation  would make any difference on that front  but even if it did could you imagine how  even more terrifying a skeleton-only  version of the shy guy stalking us would  be  yikes